sa recette est en train de faire le tour
des réseaux sociaux une tarte tatin à
laquelle marie jeanne luttons âgé de 85
ans apporte sa touche personnelle au
milieu je mets une part entière et je
mets le petit trognon et alors quand la
clac apd est retourné jeu mais
je fais de la confiture de coings
chasse et fondent et j'en mets dessus
pour qu'elle brille
depuis qu'un média en ligne est venu la
rencontrer marie jeanne a dépassé le
million de vu la vidéo a été partagé
plus de douze mille fois et génère des
commentaires par milliers j'ai été très
sensible au message parce que ça l'est
var peuvent y avait des mots gentils
qu'il y en avait même qui m'embrassait
béquille monde disait
je vais m'y mettre
parce que ça m'a tellement fait envie de
vous voir cette belle date alors je vais
me battre il y en a beaucoup qui
disaient qu'ils allaient s'y mettent bas
j'étais fier trop ça un succès qui
s'explique aussi largement par la
personnalité de la pâtissière émérite
elle a la joie de vivre
el camino michael a toujours été comme
ça on va laver six ans
avec lui
je pense qu'elle a toujours été sa
nature mamie pomme comme on l'appelle
dans sa famille a même été repéré par
une chaîne de télévision nationale elle
participera bientôt à une émission de la
chaîne ces huit je vais voir un grand
chef il s'appelle yannick alléno trois
étoiles ou en des côtes
je pense que savard des chenilles comme
ça en attendant marie jeanne
confectionne des tartes tatin pour
garder la main
magnifique
du goût
ce